problema número 15 y hablas sobre
tiendas que por cierto ya nos falta muy
poco para terminar esta sección dice una
entienda 20 un cierto tipo de calcetines
en 28 pesos este precio es 40 por ciento
mayor de lo que le cuesta a la tienda a
comprar uno de estos calcetines ok a ver
la tienda vende calcetines a 28 pesos ok
eso es importante a 28 pesos y estos 28
pesos lo podemos ver a como lo que le
cuesta a la tienda más un 40 por ciento
la tienda le gana un 40 por ciento es
decir que esto lo podemos escribir como
lo que le cuesta a la tienda
un 40 por ciento extra es decir punto 40
por lo que le cuesta a la tienda con
estos 28 pesos ellos cubren lo que les
cuesta los calcetines y un 40% más muy
bien después dice al final del año los
empleados de la tienda pueden comprar
los calcetines sobrantes a un precio del
30 por ciento menos del costo que tienen
para la tienda ok entonces al final del
año si tú eres un trabajador o un
empleado de la tienda
puedes comprar estos calcetines
sobrantes a un precio del 30 por ciento
menos es decir lo que le cuesta a la
tienda y a eso le vamos a quitar el 30
por ciento de su costo el 30 por ciento
de su costo y bueno esto es lo mismo que
el punto 7 o el punto 70 el punto 7 del
costo que es justo el precio al cual si
lo van a vender a los trabajadores a los
empleados a lo que me preguntan es
cuánto le cuestan los calcetines a los
empleados
pues a nuestra tan difícil aquí tengo
que a que los calcetines valen 28 pesos
pero esto es igual a cuánto sé más punto
40 cm esto es lo mismo que 1.40 cm
ok y 1.46 lo mismo que 28 por esto que
tengo aquí y entonces equipo despejar
hacer se va a ser igual a 28 pesos entre
1.4 entre 1.4 y cuantos esto pues veamos
28 entre 1.4 voy a recorrer el punto
para acá una vez y entonces para acá me
voy a recorrer el punto una vez aquí me
va a quedar un cero
cuántas veces cabe 14 en 28 pues son dos
veces 2 por 14 28 esto es exacto
entonces vamos bien hasta aquí me quedo
un residuo de cero bajo este cero y aquí
pongo otro cero ok
cabe 20 veces es decir lo que paga en la
tienda por los calcetines son 20 pesos
paga la tienda produzcan sixtina son 20
pesos y le ganan 8 pesos muy bien pero
imagínate que ya se acabó el año y
sobraron calcetines y tú eres un
empleado que quieres comprar uno de esos
calcetines bueno pues entonces la tienda
te lo va a vender al 70% de su costo
original y el 70 por ciento de 20 cuánto
es punto 7 por a 20 esto va a ser lo
mismo que 7 por 12 14 14 aquí pongo un
cero pero como el punto decimal se
recorre una vez entonces activar el
punto decimal es decir que a los
empleados los venden a 14 pesos la
respuesta son 14 pesos y ya está ya
tenemos aquí el problema número 15
perfecto así que vamos a trabajarla el
siguiente problema que por cierto es el
último de esta sección problema número
16 y tiene un rectángulo muy parecido a
éste un rectángulo muy parecido a éste
en el cual cada uno de sus vértices
tiene nombre cada uno
de sus vértices tienen nombre éste es
ve
y de y me dicen a sí el punto y es el
punto medio entre b y c ok vamos a tener
cuidado por aquí está el punto justo a
la mitad entre based está
y por cierto me dicen que me tomé la
siguiente figura voy a dibujar una
figura como por acá ok y esta figura la
quiero colorear a dejar agarrar una
herramienta de colores y vamos a ponerla
de este color ok
quiero ponerla de este color porque me
dicen si sabemos que el área de lo que
está sombreado es decir el área de esto
que tengo en color rosa es igual a dos
tercios ok el área de esto el área de
esto son dos tercios lo que me preguntan
es cuál es el área total del
cuadrilátero o del rectángulo
abs de ok cuál es el área total o de
otra manera
cuánto nos falta cuanto vale ese
triángulo que éste tenemos lo pequeño
que tengo aquí y bueno se me ocurre que
hay muchas
formas de resolver este problema pero la
forma en la que yo voy a resolver este
problema tiene un truco el truco es que
él es el punto medio por lo tanto si yo
parto aquí y bajo una recta sobre él voy
a hacer dos rectángulos iguales este
rectángulo de aquí y este rectángulo de
acá pero no sólo eso quiero que te des
cuenta que este cuadrado de aquí lo
puedo dividir bajo también en dos
triángulos iguales es decir que dicho de
otra manera aquí tengo un problema de
cuatro triángulos iguales este de aquí
no es de aquí es exactamente igual que
este de aquí que es exactamente igual
que éste de clint que es exactamente
igual que este de aquí que es
exactamente igual que este de aquí los
cuatro triángulos son iguales porque es
el punto medio entonces cuando yo divido
este rectángulo a la mitad y después lo
divido entre ángulos me van a quedar que
cada uno de ellos tiene la misma
y eso va a ser bastante útil porque
entonces si yo tengo que el área de
estos tres triángulos es dos tercios de
este este y este
entonces me quedaría que tres veces el
área del triángulo el área del triángulo
es igual a dos tercios porque tengo 31
23 de estos triángulos entonces yo
quiero saber el área de no es solamente
uno de esos triángulos lo que tengo que
hacer es pasar este 3 del otro lado
dividiendo o dividir t ambos lados de
esta ecuación entre 3 no va a quedar dos
tercios entre tres y bueno puedo aplicar
una ley del sándwich esto voy a quedar
este por este este por este y esto lo
mismo que 2 entre 92 o menos es decir
que cada uno de estos triángulos tiene
un área de dos novenos dejar con el
racing este triángulo tiene un área de
dos novenos este de aquí
este kit y de un área de dos novenos
este de aquí esté aquí tiene un área de
dos novenos este de aquí y éste también
tiene un área de dos o menos esté aquí
también tienen la misma área
y ahora sí sí tengo cuatro triángulos y
que saber el área total pues lo que
tengo que sumarme es el área total es
igual a dos novenos por la cantidad de
trenes los que tengo aquí uno dos tres
cuatro por cuatro lo cual por cierto
esto sabemos que es a 8
no vemos ocho novenos el área total de
este rectángulo abc de es ocho novenos
que por cierto es el inciso c así que
nos despedimos de esta sección y no te
pierdas nuestro siguiente vídeo donde
empezaremos con una nueva sección hasta
la próxima